فهذا منطاد للتجسس الصيني ما الذي كشفت ما
الذي تم كشفه بشان هذا المنطاد قامت
الولايات المتحده بالتواصل مباشره مع كافه
القنوات من اجل حمايه الشعب الامريكي
وفريقه كان قد تشاور مع جمله من الوكالات
الحكوميه وكذلك انخرطنا مع بعض حلفائنا
وشركائنا لابلاغهم عن وجود هذا المنطاد في
فضائل الجوي ونعتقد ان الظروف غير مئاتيه
لاجراء زياره في هذه الفتره
وكنت قد اوضحت لنظري ان وجودي هذا المنطاد
التجسسي هو انتهاك واضح للسياده الامريكيه
والقوانين الدوليه وهو تصرف غير مسؤول
وانه لابد من اتخاذ قرار من خلال من خلال
تاجيل هذه الزياره وابلغته
بان الولايات المتحده المستمره
بالحوار الدبلوماسي وسوف نقوم بزيارته بيج
عندما
تكون الظروف مؤذيه وفي هذا الغدون سوف
نقوم باجراء
اتصالات مستمره مع الصين
بشكل مستمر ومن الضروره ايضا ان تبقى خطوط
التواصل المفتوحه من اجل
تفادي اي سوء حسابات او صراع نقطه اخيره
وهي مهمه للغايه
العالم يتوقع من الولايات المتحده والصين
ان نقوم باداره علاقاتنا بصوره مسؤوله
والتطرق لجمله من التحديات التي تؤثر على
حياه شعوبنا وحياه شعوب كافه انحاء العالم
وان نجد طريقا مشتركا فيما بيننا و
الولايات المتحده المستمره بالتصرف بطريقه
تعكس تلك المسؤوليه فنحن نتوجه الى
شركائنا في الصين لفعل الشيء ذاته
وانا ووزير خارجيه كوريا الجنوبيه توقعنا
اتفا التي سوف تقوم بتمهيد الطريق للتعاون
في مجالات العلوم
والتكنولوجيا وهي تكمله للعمل الذي بداناه
قبل عقدين من الزمن كان حافلان بالتعاون
يتعلقان بدراسات الجامعيه والبحوث والتغير
المناخي واجرائي بحوث النواه تطويرات على
اشباه النواقل
وكذلك ان شركائنا سوف يعملون على
الاستفاده من هذا التعاون الذي سوف يتم
تجسيده من خلال بعض شركات التكنولوجيه من
اجل تصنيع
لقاحات فعاله للمنطقه هذه الترتيبات او
بالاحرى اتفاقيه اليوم سوف توسعوا نطاق
هذا التعاون مع كوريا الجنوبيه في المناطق
التي كنا قد شرعنا بالعمل بها في الفضاء
مثلا وكذلك في بعض الحقول الناشئه مثل
البايو التكنولوجيا وغيرها التعاون العلمي
هو فقط واحد من المجالات التي كانت تعمل
عليها الدولتين لمنفعه شعبنا لذلك
بالاضافه الى الامن المشترك من حيث هناك
مجموعه من قواتنا التي تجري تجري تمرينات
تمارين عسكريه مشتركه وقال الرئيس بايدن
انه لابد من تحقيق الامن والاستقرار في
هذه المنطقه وهذا يتجلى من خلال التحالف
الذي نقيمه مع كوريا الجنوبيه
والاستراتيجيه التي قمنا بطرحها في العام
الماضي لتصدي لاكثر التحديات صعوبه لكننا
اليوم نعيد تجديد التزاماتنا في التصدي
لهذه التهديدات
دفاعي عن كوريا الجنوبيه من خلال استخدام
النطاق الكامل للولايات المتحده بما في
ذلك القدرات الاستخباراتيه والصواريخ وفي
مطلع هذا الاسبوع كان الوزير اوستن قد
اجتمع بنظيره في كوريا الجنوبيه
وتطرقا الى مشاطره المعلومات حول التهديد
النووي من كوريا الشماليه
وانه لابد من العمل على ازاله
ازاله ازاله كافه المخاطر النوويه من
كوريا الشماليه واننا مستمرون في هذا
التعاون الذي سوف يعمل على التصدي
لما تقوم به كوريا الشماليه من اطلاق
صواريخهم بصوره غير مقبوله
في فصل الخريف الماضي قامت كوريا الشماليه
باجراء جمله من التجارب النوويه وسوف نعمل
ايضا على مساعده الدول في منطقه المحيط
الهادي للتصدي للتغيرات المناخيه ونعمل مع
دول اخرى لتعزيز بعض الاولويات مثل تحقيق
الازدهار في منطقه المحيط الهندي والهادي
المحيط الهندي والهادي وما بعدها والعمل
على زياده
ان شركتنا سوف تتخطى المحيط الهندي والهند
وكما اظهر الرئيس بايدن من خلال وقفته
التي ايدت اوكرانيا نعمل ايضا على تامين
كافه المصادر التي قد يحتاجها الشعب
الاوكراني في الدفاعي عن بلاده وانتم ايضا
فنحن نعمل مع تحالفا واسع وفي مطلع هذا
الاسبوع
قام الامير العام
باجراء زياره لبعضها الحلفاء وقام
بالتاكيد على ضروره الوقوف في خندق واحد